what I want to know is like with these
reality TV shows where they take this
struggling something a struggling
business or a person struggling with
issues they fix the issue on the program
how many times do you reckon it just
sticks like well they relapse after
daylight
luckily luckily we have an amazing
example and the only way that we can
definitively track it is something like
Kitchen Nightmares yeah where we can
actually just see which restaurants are
open that's true yeah and most of them
are not open still if you go through the
Kitchen Nightmares restaurant list it's
so depressing put it on your phone like
kitchen nightmare restaurants that have
closed it's literally like entire
seasons all the restaurants have closed
like it's like [ __ ] it's like okay
well Gordon couldn't help that much it's
almost as if maybe bad ownership was the
problem all along that we can't really
fix Gordon comes in just screams in our
restaurant for an hour and then he's
like [ __ ] problem solved I guess my job
here is done I have no doubt I have no
doubt some of those restaurants were
that were helped and were much better
off for it yeah man obviously that
ultimately what the TV network wants
and what the restaurant wants are two
very different yeah yeah yeah maybe
Gordon wants both but I mean ultimately
we're here to get the shots
how much how much contact time do they
actually have with Gordon apparently not
that much is it just like two days or
something yes I went on this rabbit hole
because I was so fascinated by all of
this right I wanted to know everything
about how this worked yeah yeah
apparently it would not be that much it
was literally he would come in do the
film segments and then leave yeah
um yeah that sounds about right because
he's like I've I've remodeled the place
to make it look more alive and it's like
no your production you know your
production time what do you mean like
I've come up with new recipes and like
Gordon you're a three-star Michelin Chef
there ain't no [ __ ] way you came up
with recipes with this one [ __ ]
dingy-ass restaurant I know it's
literally it just also which wouldn't
make sense because I assume the filming
said it would be so intense that it it
makes no sense that he would be Hands-On
to that degree maybe when he's there I
if you told me that he actually cares
about it I I believe that like when he's
there and he's filming the stuff but
there's just no way they've had the time
that they need well he has to care
because that's his job yeah so it's like
he's that's kind of what he's getting
painted and the show's so scripted like
yeah
so obviously there's this part there's
this part and then we have the
reconciliation and then we have yeah
owner maybe admits that he's wrong or
whatever it's just like all right
whatever so where's the part of the
episode where it says Bland yeah is
there like is there like an episode of
like Kitchen Nightmares where the the
owner just refuses to admit that they're
wrong or something oh yeah yeah yeah
so there was a a very famous episode
right uh I don't know do you even need
to explain what kitchen everyone [ __ ]
knows this is right like I think so
Gordon Ramsay fixes a struggling
restaurant everyone has seen this yeah
the little Clips make have like 50
billion views on YouTube yeah yeah so
there was one it was um the
little Baking Company right was it was
it called again
um baking company called nightmares
Kitchen Nightmares type it in yeah it
was like it I think the year that when
that episode aired or when it came out
it was like the most Googled thing of
that time right this episode was so huge
because it was like an hour long one
where they were just shouting and they
never fixed anything and everyone
thought it was like fake but after like
having a lot of people go to the
restaurant this is like full legit like
these people were like insane right and
they just somehow these producers just
stumbled upon this gold mine dude I
would love that job are you I just
finding restaurants that are [ __ ] and
like just find these crazy owners that
sounds like such a fun experience I want
to know like what is the process of
finding these restaurants right I wish
it's I'm wondering do they apply for the
show or do they like kind of I'm
guessing people do apply for the show
and they have some kind of service
application yeah okay okay okay I
remember because sometimes they mention
it in the show they applied or yeah this
person because a lot of the times think
initially they weren't exactly told what
the TV show was yeah and they're just
pitching like do you want your
restaurant to be helped on camera with
Gordon Ramsay yes and it's like this is
the shittiest Kitchen in all of North
Hampshire or whatever it's like all
right
[Music]
no one would want to eat here I'm sure
I'm sure there's a bunch of restaurants
as well that are just like so much on
the dimebrink that they're like last for
us just be like well Gordon Ramsay came
here before it shut down two days later
you know so we got our 15 minutes away
yeah I think everyone's the worst
Italian restaurant in all of Connecticut
he's an [ __ ] he's gonna fix it I
think the best like promotion they got
for the restaurant is not like Gordon
Ramsay coming in and fixing the [ __ ]
recipes and changing a few tables some
[ __ ] is being on [ __ ] Kitchen
Nightmares right of course yeah my
favorite entire segment of Kitchen
Nightmares is when they're like they
they
um obviously the restaurant is closed
and they don't they don't they don't
tell you this but they don't also try
and hide it it's really weird so there's
always that segment where Gordon goes to
the restaurant and he wants to see how
the restaurant functions and obviously
it always it always goes wrong of course
yeah it's a disaster and the cut the
restaurant is filled with customers
right yeah but they're like customers
that have been invited because they know
they're filming right because you
actually can't just go in a restaurant
have a bunch of cameras and get everyone
to sign the waivers yeah they fill them
with this thing but they don't actually
like tell you the audience that they
kind of brought all these people yeah
but then suddenly all the customers
start being picky about everything and
you're like well hold on a second I feel
like I feel like they're trying to make
this a disaster like everything has been
good and everything goes wrong everyone
always ends up fighting someone storms
out it's like yeah there is no way this
is a normal night of dining and nowhere
are these restaurants full on a normal
night of course not yeah oh that you
just remind me of like this [ __ ]
weird uncanny valley effect that I've
had with like some reality TV shows
recently have you watched like Britain's
Got Talent like Reese yeah it's awful
yeah so there's one thing that they've
added like in more recent Seasons I
don't know when they implemented this
but I remember watching Burns Got Talent
by [ __ ] 2006 2000 like all the way
back in University
um in like the early seasons and it was
like you know I had the same kind of
formula but recently they've been like
adding these shots like these what I
would call like audience audience Vox
pops right where the talent comes on
stage and then they'll be like a Vox pop
oven like audience member commenting on
the talent or something yes I have seen
this and I'm like this is so [ __ ]
weird because there is no way you just
like you you have good audio to just
capture a random audience member someone
someone here is a plant it's like you
know you know when you see some of those
like E3 trailers and they have like the
fake gaming chatter yeah or some of the
trailers that's what it [ __ ] feels
like you know I think I think I've seen
one worse like it was like a magician or
something and you kind of had like a
Unique Look to Him yeah they just
randomly as he's walking on stage it
just randomly cuts to the shot in the
audience of these two girls who are like
he kind of [ __ ] looks weird
and I'm like we didn't we didn't need
that yeah we really that was an
unnecessary reaction yeah reality even
like dying so they're just doing crazier
yeah right yeah it's it was just it's
just such a weird thing that they've
added and it feel to me it feels it
makes it feel even more fake right
because you know especially now being in
production uh seeing seeing how finicky
audio is there ain't no way you can
[ __ ] zoom in on just two random
audience members just to hope that
someone says something in
the clip that I just mentioned I
remember I was like there's no way this
is real because everyone is clapping in
this huge room and these two girls are
whispering and it's perfect audio and
I'm like I don't see a mic on you yeah
and you just happen to know to release
the camera at that particular time it's
like come on I just want to know did I
just like get a random person cute and
just be like yo so I wanted to say
something really quirky when the when
the guy comes on stage okay just just
say something really quick just comment
it doesn't know how he looks just be
mean just be me just be really really
mean yeah and then when they do the act
just be really surprised and say how
great it was right oh that was actually
kind of surprising producers are some of
like the cruelest people some of the
[ __ ] that they set up is so cool yeah oh
yeah tormenting people for fun yeah like
I mean I I've watched some videos
recently just talking about like one of
the most infamous Japanese live streams
I've oh I've seen this yeah I'm sure you
guys have seen this video as well
because it like got recommend ended for
like ages but I like they literally
trapped this poor guy this poor Japanese
guy in a room you know in a like a
random number one in the late 90s in the
late 90s and he basically had to win his
freedom through raffle tickets or raffle
prizes basically and they [ __ ]
literally started him bare naked in this
room and he I think lived in the room
for like months and months and months
and months no no that was it that was
his name yeah but it was like um the TV
show still ongoing not that segment
because it's a very famous comedy show
yes in Japan yes and they have just
segments that um they've just changed
over the years but I mean it's really
popular yeah and I think like the the
part that like the part that got me so
[ __ ] angry right was he was in this
one apartment by himself for months no
social interaction no like sometimes he
couldn't even eat well because it all
everything he won and everything he
lived on depended on raffle tickets and
raffle prizes right
um and so after months and months and
months of living in this place he uh he
he wins his freedom right and they're
like we got the producers are like we're
going to reward you we've been in there
for months with no human contact and he
literally can't eat and by raffle
there's like mail-in Raffles like in
Japan you can win a lot of stuff for
your Raffles by mailing in like there'll
be a cop they just gave him a stack of
magazines yeah they'll like enter
everything yeah and so he finally wins
this Freedom
um and then so he they reward him with
this nice trip to Korea and he he has a
fun day at the park you know they've
they film him in like an amusement park
and stuff like that uh and then they
blindfold him for his final prize yeah
and then they take him to this
mysterious place and then they ask him
to take the blindfold off and it's
another room
and then the producer just says strip
your clothes right now and as you just
see the soul leave from his body and
it's just what I'm like you're watching
this and you think I'm literally
watching torture right now it's like a
snuff film yeah it's literally a snuff
film yeah yeah Japanese game should have
been notoriously not very chilled but
people silence hand the waivers and they
do it yeah more people agree to this
yeah and especially in Japan I feel a
lot of like comedians that are up and
coming or kind of not maybe not selling
as much or you know are open to doing
like any kind of job at this point just
to like stay relevant yeah the ones who
throw themselves into these situations
because I remember like there was a
another I don't remember if it's the
same show but there was another show
similar to that where like these two
comedians were locked in two separate
rooms and I couldn't get in contact with
each other for and I think it was like a
week or two weeks and there was one door
out of their room and it leads to an
open Paddock that has a bunch of farm
animals right and what they have to do
is that they have to survive purely off
of the breast milk of those animals that
they catch for that day
for like two weeks and there's no and
and the one and the one rule is like and
the one rule is you're not allowed to
drink water so like your food and your
like drink and everything is purely
based on a how many animals you can
catch and B how much milk you can get
out yeah so someone to get the voice of
milk to another [ __ ] level man I just
I'm just imagining this and I'm like God
the the horrendous shits that they must
have just had oh God you're just
drinking milk for two weeks straight
yeah it's just horrible for your health
yeah I don't know I mean I I you know I
obviously beg the question of how real
is it obviously if you're taking it at
face value it seems [ __ ] awful yeah
I'm sure there was some behind the
scenes stuff involved where I [ __ ]
hope sad yeah
I mean with the Nabu situation I'm like
the the whole situation played out a bit
too well yeah for them for the producers
not to be like I I feel like the
producers decided what to send him at
what time because just as he was running
out of food or something he would get
like a small W like a whole bag of rice
or something and it would be like it's
like a kind of like an entire story in a
sense yeah it was weird so he was
standing like a few hundred a day right
yeah he was spending like hours a day
just like writing yeah about it it's
very interesting yeah we can't really do
it justice because yeah we're
remembering yeah